So, let me tell you how Hadoop came to be. About
ten years ago in around 2003, I was working on an Open
Source web search engine called Nutch, and
we knew it needed to be something very scalable, because the Web was you know,
billions of pages. terabytes, petabytes, of data, that we needed
to be able to process, and we set about, you know, doing the best job we
could and it was tough. We got things up and running on four or five machines
not very well, and around that time Google
published some papers. About how they were doing
things internally. Published a paper about their distributed
file system, TFS. and about their processing, framework, MapReduce.
So my partner and I, at the time, in this project, Mike
Cafarella. Said about trying to reimplement these in Open Source. So that
more people could use them than just folks at Google. Took us a couple of years,
and we had Nutch up and running on, instead of four or five
machines, on, 20 to 40 machines. It wasn't perfect,
it was it wasn't, wasn't totally reliable, but it
worked. And we realize that to get it to the
point where it was scaled to thousands of machines,
and be as bullet proof as it needed to be,
would take more than just the two of us,
working part time. Around that time, Yahoo approached me and
said they were interested in investing in this. So
I went to work for Yahoo in January of 2006.
First thing I did there, was, we took the parts of Nutch that were a distributed
computing platform, and put em into a separate
project. A new project christened Hadoop. Over the
next couple years, with, Yahoo's help, and the
help of others. we took Hadoop, and really
got it to the point where it did
scale to petabytes, and running on thousands of processors.
And doing so quite reliably. it spread to lots of companies. and mostly in the
Internet sector, and became quite a success. after that, we, we started to see
a bunch of other projects grow up around it. And Hadoop's grown to be the kernel
of a, which, pretty much an operating system for big data. we've got,
we've got tools that, allow you to, more easily do, MapReduce programming.
so, you can develop using SQL or a data flow language called Pig. and
we've also got the beginnings of
higher-level tools. We've got interactive SQL with
Impala. We've got Search. and so we're really seeing this develop to being a
general purpose platform for data processing. that scale's much better and
that it is much more flexible than anything that's, that's, else is out there.